ce pont c'est l'une des deux voies
d'accès à l'usiné de production d'eau
potable mais surtout l'unique solution
pour accéder en voiture à certaines
habitations
lorsque la rivière blanche est en crue
l'annoncé de sa fermeture a été faite
aux habitants par courrier le 5 août
dernier et depuis dans le quartier
l'inquiétude règne
on nous dit que c'est pour les travaux
mais les travaux qui vont commencer à
partir de juillet 2020 et nous sommes en
route 2019 dans ça fait pratiquement un
non on ne peut pas rester un non sens le
pont c'est pas possible notamment que
nous sommes en période cyclonique
c'est à dire que si on est en période
cyclonique quand il ya les crues les
montées d'eau on ne peut pas accéder
on ne peut pas accéder à la rivière donc
il faut bien qu'on ait un autre passage
ce kinésithérapeute empreinte la
structure métallique deux fois par
semaine pour soigner ses patients
sans ce pont selon lui l'accès aux soins
sera plus difficile
je viens de l'apprendre et du coup oui
en effet je me dis comment je vais faire
si le pont est fermé parce que le seul
autre accès c'est la rivière qui est là
bas qui est pas enfin à mon sens encore
une fois un qui n'est pas très
sécuritaire
je n'aime pas mais j'aime pas passer sur
les gays quand ya de l'eau et en
particulier si une période de crue ou si
les conditions météorologiques sont pas
bonnes donc le seul accès à part la
rivière ce serait celui-là donc si on le
ferme je sais pas comment on peut
accéder aux riverains qui sont de
l'autre côté
dans la lettre adressée aux riverains
l'espace sud indique un pont qui
présente des détérioration structurelle
importante
un platelage en bois endommagés est une
structure métallique inquiétante et
dangereuse
cette décision de fermeture serait avant
tout une question de sécurité
un nouveau pont sera construit à
proximité du gué de la rivière blanche
il devrait être livré en janvier 2021 au
plus tard mais en attendant ce pont de
bois par exister longtemps au passage
des véhicules faudrait le neutraliser
pour les véhicules mais nous proposions
de mettre en fait une espèce de
platelage sur un côté permettant aux
piétons de l'utiliser béton motos vélos
voir fauteuil roulant ou lit médicalisé
sur le faut s'il faut une intervention
d'urgence des services de secours ou
d'une ambulance
la seule solution qui donc pourrait
proposer pour l'instant ça se règle en
lice garde le garé leurs véhicules
en amont du pont et après rentrer chez
eux à pied de son côté la municipalité
dit avoir adressé un courrier au préfet
dans l'espoir de la mise en place d'un
ouvrage provisoire pour la circulation
des véhicules en période de crue pour
l'heure officiellement aucune date de
fermeture du pont n'a été acté